here's what my experience of Jay
Baruchel very very funny guy also an
incredibly nice person well thank you
very much our lives it would be a jerk
thing for me to be like yeah agreed
totally I am nice yeah I was trying to
trick you into doing that no wait will
you an aspirin early in the morning you
know part of the niceness may come from
being Canadian I think I know you were a
very proud Canadian indeed which is a
good thing it's a wonderful country I
think so - yeah you know what's
interesting is you've probably been
aware of this but since the latest
political turmoil in our country going
back a couple of years a lot of people
say it's their default thing to say well
time to move to Canada yes as a Canadian
how do you feel about that depends
depends we're talking about yeah so you
want it you want the route you want the
right certain Americans to move up north
maybe everybody all all are welcome
maybe not all but a lot are welcome no I
think I think the world needs could do
with more Canadians so look I think
everybody says that it's incredibly hard
to be to move to Canada and become
Canadian is it really yes it is a very I
said that condescending way don't you
just want didn't go I guess I'll do it
I'm sure it's a you know it's a it's a
it's a multi-year process and it also it
really does get very cold i I don't know
how many people realize that that it's
like routinely minus 30 and 30
centimeter do you know what centimeters
are you're no rude already screwed now
we refuse to we everybody apply yeah
applauded the metrics is yeah this is
the same crowd that sad El Chapo's in
jail
be wary of them you know you are it does
feel like is it true it's such a cliche
that Canadians are kind and nice and
sort of inclusive is that true like when
you think about yourself and your family
is it ingrained if you're Canadian I
would say I'd say that like two big
pastimes in my household were self-doubt
and not wanting to inconvenience
strangers and so like I live I live in
Toronto right now and a few years ago I
went back home to Montreal on my
birthday and my mom and stepdad came to
pick me up at the airport and they had
spent time and money on having these
t-shirts made that said something to the
effect of like Jays bitching 35th beat
or something like that that's that's was
very sweet and they were there waiting
in the airport for me but their jackets
were fully done up and they literally
just waited till we were in the car and
went oh yeah we also had these babies
they couldn't do this at the end there
were too worried about you know
bothering people it's not everyone
exactly right so you don't want to make
a big fuss and offend anyone so yeah
where's the thought that counts